la dernière invitée de cette édition du
7 8 de ce 7 novembre et créatrice de
bijoux bonsoir patricia vilain merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau vous vous
êtes lancé dans cette aventure de
création de bijoux il ya tout juste
trois ans en tant qu'auto entrepreneur
depuis voisins le bretonneux et pourtant
vous n'étiez pas destinée vivre de cette
passion c'est plutôt dans le cadre d'une
reconversion professionnelle
vous avez passé 38 ans en tant que
comptable et ensuite vous avez décidé
après un licenciement de vous lancer
dans cette passion tout à fait qu'est ce
qui vous a motivé pour vous lancer
véritablement dans cette nouvelle
aventure en fait j'avais fait quelques
années auparavant des relooking de mes
vieux collier et j'étais j'avais
beaucoup d'encouragements de mes amis de
certaines personnes en me disant
tu as de l'or dans les mains vas-y vas-y
vas-y et vas-y et j'attendais et le
moment est venu effectivement au moment
de mon licenciement ça a été
effectivement l'occasion de me lancer
alors c'était il ya trois ans oui vous
avez lancé cette aventure en tant
qu'auto-entrepreneur ça fonctionne bien
aujourd'hui oui enfin je suis très
satisfaite du résultat aussi bien sur le
plan financier que sur le plan humain
aussi même de la liberté pour travailler
dans une entreprise le cadre d'une
entreprise à passer être son propre
patron et vivre de sa passion ça change
un petit peu voilà le plan financier
n'est pas le plus important pour moi
c'est plutôt la qualité de vie que je
recherche et aujourd'hui je peux dire
que je suis pleinement heureuse de faire
ce que je fais et vous avez l'intention
continuer encore longtemps tout à fait
ça va se poursuivre on va parler
justement ces créations quels sont les
types de bijoux que vous réalisez
comment créer un bijou
par exemple celui que j'ai sur moi en
règle générale quand je travaille je me
mets ma table je prends deux trois
perles et ça se fait tout seul vous
travaillez pas à voir avec des schémas
des nazis vous réfléchissez pas
spécialement c'est très très rare il ya
un an et demi charnue de corse sur le
bateau j'ai eu des idées de créations
qui sont toujours dans un carnet parce
que j'ai tout le temps tout le temps des
idées voilà je vois deux ou trois perles
de trois belles choses qui peuvent aller
avec les associe et le reste en fait je
m'assois matin mais je travaille sans ça
coule tout seul en fait c'est formidable
dans tous les styles pour les bijoux
c'est vraiment tous les styles qui vous
intéresse alors il ya effectivement je
travaille un petit peu de temps en temps
du d'un des choses comme ça du quelques
colliers en bois
je vais effectivement des petits
colliers pour enfants je travaille plus
en matière et il ya des choses qui
m'intéressent pas donc je ne les fait
pas c'est par rapport à la demande aussi
peut-être est-ce que les demandes sont
très différentes fonctions de la mode en
fonction des attentes des saisons alors
je ne m'occupe pas du tout de la mode
mais colliers sont chez chantal raisner
les alors il qu'ils aient une boutique
de prêt-à-porter à saint quentin depuis
deux ans je m'occupe absolument pas de
la mode je fais des colliers
selon mes goûts et de toutes les
couleurs et je vends tout le temps tous
mes collier vous avez des années où
c'est pas la mode du rouge moi je fais
du rouge il vous avez des clients qui
sont très contentes d'avoir des colis
rouge alors que chaque pièce est unique
vous voulez des clés vous en faites de
petites quantités par exemple celui là
c'est un modèle qui est déposé à l'inpi
donc j'ai quelques modèles qui sont
déposées et après ça peut être un modèle
jusqu'à 6 je vais rarement de l'a26 ce
qu'il faut quand même que ça reste du
modèle unique vous avez mentionné de
l'inpi ça correspond à c'est une société
où on dépose ou les gens déposent leur
modèle d'accord pour la création de
bijoux tout à fait que ce soit
effectivement que ce soit bien clair
donc pour cela pour se les procurer ces
bijoux vous nous l'avez dit vous mettez
en vente mettait en vente dans certaines
boutiques oui mais vous mettez en vente
aussi sur votre site internet absolument
voilà c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
c'est plutôt le réseau qui marche le
mieux le réseau 2g de personnes à sa
contourner en taux d'entrepreneurs ce
qui est important c'est de se constituer
un réseau il faut trois ans pour se le
faire je le serai swing je peux dire
aujourd'hui que le réseau je lai je peux
dire aujourd'hui gelé le réseau s'était
véritablement difficile justement quand
vous êtes arrivé si dans ce milieu on se
dit créatrice de bijoux voilà c'est un
métier dans lequel on se lance et une
passion mais ce qu'on peut en vivre est
ce que ces voix là il ya des bijoux on
en trouve presque partout aujourd'hui
oui mais la chance que j'ai c'est par
exemple celui que j'ai sur moi quand je
veux trouver de nouvelles adresses je me
présente chez les dans les boutiques où
j'expose tout le temps avec ce collier
la cena colis qui est très très porteur
quand je dis aux gens je suis créatrice
de bijoux souvent on dit on vous a
remarqué en arrivant et je leur réponds
c'est le but aussi quels sont les
matériaux sur ce collier que vous portez
d'ailleurs ça c'est du métal argenté ça
c'est du métal argenté ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle une perle magique donc qui donne
effectivement cette impression de
briller en fonction de comment on la
regarde et puis des perles les perles de
qualité c'est un peu votre bijou
porte-bonheur oui absolument absolument
vous vous rendez à domicile également à
l'or peut malheureusement peut donc
aujourd'hui effectivement j'aimerais
accès l'année prochaine la vente à
domicile c'est un petit peu mon objectif
aujourd'hui
j'aime beaucoup le la rencontre avec les
gens j'aime beaucoup bavarder aussi donc
je vais effectivement des ateliers
adultes des ateliers enfants également
des anniversaires pour les enfants qui
marchent
bon là j'en ai pas fait depuis un petit
moment mais les parents sont bien du
temps oui les parents sont tout le temps
très très contente j'ai fait
effectivement l'année dernière des
animations dans une ville marly le à
marly-le-roi je peux le dire j'ai
également des commandes pour l'année
prochaine toujours à marly également sur
guyancourt pour faire effectivement des
animations avec les enfants
donc voila et puis je voudrais aussi
mettre l'accent cette année je vais
faire deux choses dans ma ville puisque
j'habite à voisins le bretonneux je vais
faire du téléthon donc je vais
effectivement proposé aux enfants de
faire des petits bijoux j'ai fait
l'année dernière guyancourt ça très très
très bien marché pour le téléthon oui
donc cette année ce sera vous l'avez dit
rien d'étonnant oui et puis je faire
également marché de noël de
voisins-le-bretonneux cette année donc
ça permettra aux gens qu'ils ne
connaissent pas forcément qu'ils
connaissent mes cartes de visite parce
que mes cartes souvent me dit ah on
connaît ça et nous ne connaît pas donc
effectivement j'aurais à max est un
petit peu plus son voisin cette année le
téléthon qui permettra de reverser ça
permettra de reverser des fonds tout à
fait damman pour votre participation sur
ce rendez-vous vient rendez vous
également sur les différents ateliers
vous pouvez proposer le 10 novembre
c'est à magny les hameaux oui absolument
alors il est complet mais bon je le dis
je t'ai effectivement des ateliers la ji
alors ça ça devra sera acquis même si
c'est complet ça s'adresse à qui la
ville il y aura sept adultes et deux
enfants une petite fille de 4 ans une
autre je crois qu'il ya six ans et après
des adultes alors qu'ils vont faire
effectivement ce qu'on vient de voir en
ligne là les petits saluts
ya des personnes qui vont faire des à
lui d'autres qui vont vouloir se lancer
dans une création donc elles m'ont dit
thiat patricia sur internet on a vu tel
collier donc moi je vais amener
un mélange de pertes pour que la
personne puisse faire effectivement sa
création propre parce qu'il n'est pas
question de copier sur ce que je fais qu
est-ce qu en fait c'est le but c'est
d'apprendre aux gens la technique et
puis les désaxés aussi pour que leur
collier soit équilibré enfin selon mes
goûts on va dire mais je laisse aussi
après la personne aussi avoir un
certaines directives pour qu'elle est
effectivement acolyte lui qui lui
ressemble une dernière question le prix
parce que ça coûte cher de fabriquer
déjà de faire appel à vos services et
puis de fabriquer son collier et bien
les ateliers vous voulez dire les
ateliers là les ateliers je prends 6
euros par personne et pour faire par
exemple à sautoir je prend 9 euros et
l'emploi concerne vos créations si on
veut se procurer les créations comme par
exemple collègues vous porter sur vous
alors le collier sur moi c'est le plus
cher de ce que je vends il est à 48
euros et puis les petits à lui que je
fais pour les enfants pour le téléthon
par exemple le téléthon il sera en vente
à 3 euros et moi je les vends 6 et donc
ma gamme va de 6 à 48 euros merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau nous parler de vos
activités je rappelle que vous êtes
créatrice de bijoux vos articles sont en
vente sur le site internet qui s'est
affichée au cours de l'entretien
pourquoi pas une idée cadeau pour les
les fins d'années il ya ces ateliers
aussi à destination des enfants et des
adultes merci à vous pour conclure cette
édition du 7 8 je vous propose à présent
de revenir sur les principaux titres du
jour les sujets que vous avez découvert
au cours de cette édition une
manifestation plutôt original dans les
rues de versailles l'association
s'appelle l214 elle milite contre la
vente de issus de plus élevés en
batterie à l'association a déjà collecté
25 mille signatures un concours
difficile qui se prépare en 3 ans un
titre prestigieux celui de mof autrement
dit meilleur ouvrier de france dans les
yvelines ils sont sept lauréats deux
d'entre eux étaient d'ailleurs en
plateau avec nous ce soir au début de
cette édition et christophe à ton qui
est cuisinier et puis véronique à
belgrade que vous voyez sur ces images
elle a reçu ce diplôme de meilleur
ouvrier de france pour son activité de
peintre sur porcelaine un travail
délicat et très prenant
et puis les hip hop game ce dans le
cadre du projet pulsations urbaine un
atelier s'est déroulée à magny les
hameaux en attendant la grande
manifestation du 17 novembre à
guyancourt vous y avez peut-être assisté
ce matin la manifestation à versailles
devant un supermarché d'un collectif qui
demande la fin de la commercialisation
et des oeufs de poules élevées en
batterie le point sur leurs
revendications lac anthony rech et
patrick jacques de dixmude ils n'étaient
pas nombreux ce mercredi devant
l'enseigné monoprix de versailles
pourtant depuis un an ces militants de
l'association l214 manifeste pour
inciter le groupe à ne plus vendre deux
de poules élevées en cage selon eux
leurs conditions de vie sont indignes le
groupe milite pour un élevage uniquement
au sol ou en plein air un fonctionnement
déjà adoptée en allemagne ou en belgique
alors qu'en france 80 % des poules sont
élevées en batterie c'est pas juste une
volonté d'une association de protection
animale isolé mais que leur clientèle
est d'accord avec cette démarche refuse
elle aussi les oeufs de poules élevées
en cage pour sont des conditions
ignobles de vie pour les poules et que
vraiment dans une société évoluée en
devrait on ne devrait pas accepter ce
type de production du tout c'est
vraiment le minimum qu'on pourrait
accorder aux animaux quoi la pétition
lancée par l'association l214 a déjà
réuni plus de 25 mille signatures suite
à des discussions avec l'association
l'enseigne monoprix a réagi en retirant
de ses rayons les oeufs de poules
élevées en cage de sa marque
distributeur dans une trentaine de
magasins de la région lyonnaise une
évolution sous forme de tests qui se
terminera fin
décembre 17,8 pour ce soir merci de nous
avoir suivis comme chaque jour sur tv
fil 78 n'oubliez pas que vous retrouvez
toutes nos archives sur notre site
internet vous pouvez également commenter
cette émission le 7 8 sur les réseaux
sociaux hashtag le 7,8 à demain jeudi
dès 18h sur tv fils
monde